hot breath and when you when you're
developing material like what is your
writing process because even just like a
word choice
of you you talking about avocados and
using this word
hatch it's i just love word choice and
like the specificity between like a
laugh and a lull can be that one word
and you just
using hatch i was like oh she like gets
into the nitty-gritty
of like word choice and really how you
can paint a picture with a single word
so like what is your writing process in
developing a tight bit
um well i definitely probably start off
with twitter
so it's an idea and it usually feels
like a topic
sentence of a paragraph and so
i generally go off of a feeling that i
have
so like i'll just for example the
avocado joke like i don't know i just
had i remember one night i'm like
i the whole time i was walking to my
show in my mind i was stressed that i
was like i have
three avocados at home that are like
are about to expire and i really like i
don't want to throw them away and i keep
wasting food like that and then i was
making me laugh that it was like
taking up so much mental real estate in
my mind and then i thought it would be
funny if i just cancelled
shows so i could just stay at home and
make sure i could eat my
avocados so then it felt like they look
like eggs
and then they and kind of like an
incubation and so i thought of the word
hatch
and yeah and i actually really
like enjoy doing stuff that way and
that's
that's how it started so it started off
as a tweet and then when i went on stage
you i end up like tagging on stage so i
do a lot of my writing
as i go up on stage because sometimes
when the audience gives you feedback
that it feels good you want to keep
writing that wave and
and then i'll talk that bit until it i
kill it
and then i know where to stop oh i love
are you so are you thinking through when
you think okay
i have three avocados at home oh no i
better get back oh this is funny that
i'm even thinking this
and then are you like avocados avocados
well they look like eggs
maybe they hatch like does it come
together did it come together all as
you're walking to the show
um yeah or just like you know you just
as you say something on stage it's just
like
if you're in a good mood and you're
feeling really funny that night and the
crowd is really responsive to you
it puts me in that zone of like just
tagging and being
thinking of my mind seems to get more
relaxed
and then it kind of comes to you while
you're on stage and then
you know in a situation like that you
call it mapping what what does this feel
like to you and then you use
other elements from that comparison and
see if it works with
what you're talking about can you go
into mapping more
yeah i guess it's a term that you use
like i learned it in
sketch writing and it's like taking
one incident and being like this is a
very similar feeling to this other
incident i'm trying i can't think of an
example right now which is so
infuriating um let me see if i have
um i guess one example i remember one
time
um you know how girls always have the
dilemma of um
like am i gonna cut my bangs or i'm
going to cut my ba
like it's a constant thing in our life
of cutting our bangs
and i was just thinking how like it just
seems like
a really weird like a small problem but
it feels like a big problem to us
that so i wrote a sketch of us in a like
log cabin and we're a poor family
and then i mapped it over that and the
problems that you would have
in a depression or in a dust bowl
and then i did it with cutting bangs
so i i put the bangs in that scenario
and i think that would be what you would
consider mapping
oh and then maybe like common phrases
from the dust bowl
you may just apply to cutting bangs
yeah that it works it works that way
like i had a whole monologue of my great
the grandmother going through
her generations of cutting bangs and
stuff like that that's what they did
so and if it like people see it better
or like one time i wear i felt like i
was always working on my printer and i
was like this is like working on some
this equivalent of working on your car
but it's not as cool so then i
you write that way so that's just like
one technique
that i use to like expand a bit
it works in sketch that's where i got it
do you have any other techniques you
could uh
share with us uh
that's the only one i can think of i'm
sure as i talk more along i'll probably
like um
remember comparisons are always good i
try not to use
um what is it that's like if this was
like this
because i feel like that's a very
obvious way to state something but if
you use it in a hyperbole
hyperbolically i don't know how you
pronounce it um
i think people will know what you're
getting at without having to state it
and it feels more effective that way
oh if it's almost like more
conversational or comes off more natural
yeah like treating it treating a
lightweight
subject as if it had it's a very serious
death like a like a traumatic experience
i think is always kind of like a funny
way of treating things
yeah that is a really intriguing
contrast i'm going to start looking
for more in my own material and my own
ideas
of you even like the avocado one
about the stakes heightened so much i'm
actually going to cancel
shows for this and it's almost like the
bigger the contrast maybe the more
comedy potential yeah i
i guess it's just kind of like uh
i don't know i don't even know how to
explain it but like
i don't know i feel like sometimes um
like if you're a really dirty comic
i feel like it's good to dress really
nice like
i like the ying and the yang it's a very
nice balance
and i think people like it and it's a
way to soften
things and get and you can get away with
a lot
more
you